starla compact part two I started a bit
late but that's okay
I don't think people are gonna Oh
Siebert started his video could let oh
we can open here as well wait I'm not
recording now I'm recording no you're
the one starting late yeah whatever
oh we can go here as well hey do we
progress we can go here it alone was a
different patch yeah no starch oh oh
it's locked
thanks frickin nerd
you and your [ __ ] ideas no okay is
your computer in you yes oh yeah
I told you I got a new computer oh yeah
Africa this is the graphics are pretty
awesome
I got a pistol die freaking blood
everywhere
oh geez anyway oh that was awesome do
that again I can shoot them when they're
like behind covering if you lift a month
yes oh look what I have watch from the
car
oh [ __ ] I died I died what what I saved
you and I died I don't really get ya the
same thing maybe hmm-hmm-hmm no
seriously why should we die when we save
each other I mean all games like nope
no shame for you deuces oh yeah Kiki
that's my guy
you got a new face and you've got a new
face and I got a new gun oh yeah
okay lift them up for me I mean I'm
shooting them like I go down so [ __ ]
quickly holy [ __ ]
save me it's so [ __ ] I can't hold
them for you look I'm holding all these
penis
again mother Oh God you typically don't
how do I reload checkpoint down not
mission did your face difficulty yes I
freaking change - it's your fault
yeah it's your fault it's your fault
yeah I was playing on the hardest before
you came and then my penis
exploded yes
you got a new face and I got a little
girl me luck
no a gift today wait it wasn't it why do
you do that it's not even good night yes
see this ah since I got a gun when I do
it Oh slow mo you liked writing they
like right slow okay relax let me lift
them up for me
maybe if I die if how that relates I
don't know
gee oh god oh god I'm done I'm done bro
I need to save you I'm holding you so
hard stance down peace I need to be
closer to you can you lift them up for
me if they get close enough yesh Oh on
the side on the side over their skin
supposed to be short too but I don't
really mind but it's what we need to
figure something out
don't don't do that thing what does he
call when you do that minor controls
let's call it micro Corinne you've got a
new face and you've got a new face and
yeah just kill that guy I guess it was
awesome when you lift him up and then I
was like no no don't take my spot lift
him up kill him okay do it again
wait really show me your face I go slow
more when you lift up show me your face
no it isn't showing wait I gotta
you know you have to say it more
convincingly yeah wise
yeah that's convincing me uh-huh
Gundam for you oh god I'm why don't you
come carries it to me cuz I'm stuck to
the wall and you like it why made read
the stopping read don't die oh my gosh
I know but still why D be such a gay
Russian guy um no cuz I'm your brother
so you send me oh god oh god oh god
we need a tactic and you need to up
memory full [ __ ] beside what you got
earlier why does it say memory full I'm
all what do you mean memory full oh my
god okay breath back something maybe I
should play the gay Russian guy maybe
you should maybe should but don't we
have to see the cuts and I get don't
wait oh yeah I don't want to see the cut
scene again how would I
oh yeah check alack I can hold him for
you oh yeah you can do that it's like oh
my God look at me Mom oh don't mind if I
do
don't [ __ ] up now oh [ __ ] don't you [ __ ]
up now
I never thought it we should let them
come at us oh you like when people come
at you but I don't like when you die
it's you don't have much time you don't
I got you bro I got you what up you if
you shoot and now you stand hair and
revive you okay oh they can only come
through you're right yes I hope well we
can't do any words anyway or can we
don't son-of-a-bitch me
that's a nice that he's coming at me I'm
holding for you there you go there you
go there's another one holy moly no I
can say him I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead
come with me bro he died before you it's
okay I killed him that's why he died
stupid I don't have much help at all
don't you get helpful where are you
right you look so gay when you remind me
yeah I'm like professed and you're like
no sweet brofist and you're like now I
know come on wait I might as well just
die and then you defy me or something
cuz I don't have much oh stop puking
this is serious business but pure
serious business yeah I guess you're
right yeah I really need to kill myself
it's like oh no [ __ ]
emo
where is he yes [ __ ] ah but I'm gonna
hold up thank you
he day oh we did it
whistles I swear a prophecy it's fine
bro fish you're like yeah okay now you
gotta professed me do I really do the
brofist stuff yeah you do like profits
you want this oh oh sure tears another
one get him gah hey wait wait look ma
holding for me
all in for me I put bullets in him you
hold them for me I don't have much time
at all oh okay I got Emma there is
someone else there I'm holding I'm so
dead I'm holdin it's at the door ah well
you know kill him I want to do it man
least time oh that was man that was
actually faster done
creepy noise music whatever working here
stupid killing the TV's ah what's going
on like a little TVs can't kill TVs
what's with the frickin noise oh uh
we're supposed to go here it sound like
you're for yours I did I did something
creepy about happen what the [ __ ] what
them there's a gun someone in here pick
it out never gonna like that box of
[ __ ] hard
uh-huh
I don't know why there's creepy noise
can you open for me
maybe maybe thank you was it creepy
noise I don't get it yeah I've heard the
I can salvia it's not obvious it's no
god oh god oh god oh god oh god okay I'm
gonna throw Nate what is why did you do
that body control okay oh god oh god oh
god save me save me now this that killed
someone I'm so dead pew pew pew oh yeah
I'm that I'm that Rufus me Rufus me
Rufus bro bro fist no
ah profit profit profit profit time I go
down so freakin quickly that's what she
said oh I guess you have innate or
something now you have anything no I
just have this Michael Sheen
okay I can't even go slow-mo
it's completely out oh okay hey what
okay what did you do have no idea
brofist me Oh God Oh Raffi's me that
[ __ ] I think I can do this but I have no
idea what this does it makes me blue you
should do it okay I'm doing it it's our
picture professor I need a brofist you
suppose enough on the one over fist you
crap
pitching attempt what those [ __ ]
didn't you run so profesh mode no I was
Provost but you were like man I'm just
gonna [ __ ] oh god memorable oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] penis okay well we passed this
part to thingy way too long anyway so
ascended here support